well he changed a lot because I realized
that I hated poor teaching I mean that's
you know I I realized being in the
jungle that what I have thought I could
do I mean changing the way politics were
being done in Colombia was was not
possible the way I wanted to do it by
confronting what by denouncing i was i
was you know struggling against
corruption and the only thing I my only
weapon was to put the truth in the
media's and of course it made me win
lots of enemies that didn't want me to
to just denounce what was happening and
I'm not sure that was the the most
helpful helpful way of doing things I I
thought also that we should change laws
and I don't think today that laws can
change really the reality of the country
I think I think today that if I want for
example if my goal is to change Columbia
which it is because i really think
colombia has to change in many many ways
i think it has to be a very profound
nearly spiritual maturing process in the
climbing society because i think you
have to first be aware of what's
happening and it's not easy because many
people don't want to see what's
happening they want to stay in the
comfort zone once you're aware and you
admit that you want to be aware you want
to be wanting to change which is not
evident either because some people are
you know having benefits have interest
of not changing the situation so you
need to produce a desire for change
and and you have to and only when the
society gets together and and and ask
for those changes then you can deliver
and I don't think you can do it the
other way around so I'm just waiting to
see if Colombians can change in their
hearts being more solidary more more
compassionate to the others and wanting
really to to see deep changes in how we
roll the country
yes exactly thank you that's a very good
way to put it short and lingering too
much the deads awaits it's a grassroot
thing it doesn't come from the top it
has to come from the from the people